This was the motivation for coming up
with this abstraction of distributed shared memory
in a cluster. The idea is that we want to give the illusion to the application
programmer writing and explicitly parallel program. That
all of the memory that's in the
entire cluster is shared. They are not
physically shared, but the DSM library is going to
give the illusion to the threads running on each
one of these processes that all of this memory
is shared. And therefore they have an easier transition
path for instance, from going from a sequential program or
going from a program that they've written on an
SMP. To a program that runs on the cluster, because
they don't have to think in terms of message
passing. But they can think in terms of shared memory,
sharing pointers across the entire cluster, and
so on. Also, since we are providing a
shared memory semantic in the DSM library for
the application program There is no need for
marshalling and unmarshalling arguments that are being passed
from one processor to another and so on.
All of that is being handled by the fact that there is shared memory. So when
you make a procedure call, and that procedure
call is touching Some portion of memory that
happens to be on a remote memory. That
memory is going to magically become available to the thread
that is making the procedure call. In other
words, the DSM abstraction gives the same level
of comfort to a programmer who's used to
programming on a true shared memory machine when they
moved to cluster. Because they can use same set of primitives,
like locks and barriers for synchronization, and the Pthread [GUESS] style of
creating threads, that will run on different nodes of the cluster. And that's
the advantage of DSM style of writing an explicitly parallel program.